david bonjour alors un 14 juillet
particulier on le disait encore une fois
cette année sous le signe du coc vide
parce sanitaire obligatoire pour
assister au défilé
oui levin fête nationale sous haute
sécurité un sanitaire deux jours après
les annonces chocs d'emmanuel macro le
protocole pour ce 14 juillet est un très
strictes environ 25000 personnes sont
attendues chacune d'entre elles elle
devra présenter un pass sanitaire c'est
à dire un schéma de vaccination complet
la présentation d'un test négatif ou
bien encore est la preuve d'une immunité
récente au co vida 19 pas à d'exception
pour ce 14 juillet le port du masque est
obligatoire et la préfecture de police a
été très clair dans ce dans son
communiqué elle recommande aux
spectateurs de se présenter sur place
en avance pour maximiser leurs chances
d'entrer elle car pas tout le monde ne
pourra assister à cette cérémonie
dispositif de sécurité renforcé
évidemment instauré de 6h30 à 14h dans
les secteurs des champs-elysées de la
concorde et de l'assemblée nationale une
organisation finalement à laquelle les
français vont devoir s'habituer pour ce
type d'événement mais aussi pour les
événements du quotidien partir du mois
d'août
oui david olivier ferrand qui a
d'ailleurs détaillé un hier soir les
contours du pass sanitaire est
nécessaire aux employés travaillant dans
les lieux publics
hors de question qu'un client d'un bar
ou d'un restaurant soit servie par un
employé et qui n'est lui-même pas
vaccinaux qui ne présentent pas un passe
un sanitaire une prise de position qui a
fait bondir les syndicats qui ont
demandé un report de sa mise en
application des lettres accepté par
olivier avérant mais dès le 1er août
tout assez un salarié à devront avoir
reçu au moins une dose de vaccin écouter
les salariés des établissements qui
reçoivent du public
là aussi nous les enjoignant à se
vacciner très vite
mais là aussi nous donnons un petit
détail ils devront avoir reçu leurs
premières doses de vaccination au plus
tard le 1er août sans quoi à compter du
30 août
ça sera un test tous les deux jours
s'ils veulent continuer à travailler
une incitation qui peut forcément
s'apparenter à une sorte d'obligation et
surtout à une discrimination pour
l'ensemble de ses salariés qui sortent
déjà d'une année est très compliqué mais
le choix
n'est pas donnée est finalement eu
l'idée de faire un test pcr tous les
jours pour travailler et plus que la
désagréable le mois de septembre un
risque donc d'être sous tension autre
délai accordé aux français les
adolescents ne seront finalement pas
obligé de se soumettre aux passes annie
terre dès le 21 juillet une mesure elle
qui était jugée est trop rapide alors
que la vaccination elle n'est pas
ouverte à cette année ouverte à cette
tranche d'âge que depuis peu écouté les
ados n'auront pas se priver ou se
soumettre à des tests récurrents ils
sont toutefois invités à se faire
vacciner rapidement mais seront exemptés
de passes annie terre jusqu'au 30 août
dans les lieux où il sera exigé
à partir du 21 juillet afin de ne pas
gâcher les vacances des familles pour
eux le passé ni terre s'appliquera dans
tous les endroits où ils s'appliquent à
compter du 30 août
d'autre part olivier véran annoncé que
la vaccination serait complète considéré
comme complète en france dans le cadre
du pass sanitaires une semaine seulement
après l injection de la seconde dose et
non plus l 14 alors malgré ces
assouplissements de nombreuses
interrogations persistent pour les
français qu'ils considèrent être pris de
court pour la plupart et par là même à
d'inégalités renforcer un à cause de ce
pass à sanitaires merci beaucoup
david pour toutes ces précisions